you've got to shell out 17 grand and
that's the list price
we haven't even factored in people who
are gonna go aftermarket and bejeweled
theirs I mean we could be getting into
tens of thousands of Jacob the jeweler
site type dollars we're talking big
bucks Stephanie for that big watch and I
think you know the real question is how
many of those are they gonna make or
what does this make their brand I mean
this is this is an interesting branding
exercise for this company to really go
after this luxury thing and I wonder how
much it's and we don't really know we
may never know how many they actually
sell at those kinds of prices but what
it does do is establish Apple and this
watch as a premium thingy to wear on
your wrist thingy Cory that's such a
sophisticated technical technical term
jewelers use that it's a it's a business
know so think about these numbers right
so think about what what they've done in
the past and they've launched a new
product Apple's bigger than it's ever
been it's bigger than any company that's
ever been in the public markets but when
in the first year of the iPhone you saw
someone selling about a you know a
million four and they had launched it
late in the year to be sure and but over
time that Rampton of arguably the most
important products ever made at least by
a single company well if you want to
look at the iPad it started a much
bigger level and grew even faster
although it has petered out and even
been falling late it was started about
seven and a half million a year so the
predictions are out there as high as 40
million watches is here but that
expensive watch I think is more of a
thought leader than actually a leader of
them okay McCrory let's talk about who's
going to buy it Scott Galloway who truly
knows brands has said the Chinese
they're gonna buy it they're gonna love
to show it off but when I think about
this watch and people who love luxury
watches you can wear that what you want
a Rolex of Cartier and IWC you where you
put it away you can put it on in five
years this is a tech product a gadget
and also a year from now when they come
out with a new one is this you're gonna
be just in your tech graveyard with a
Walkman well I you know I think it's
interesting interesting discussion right
so first of all I think there's this
tendency to say who's gonna buy it the
Chinese who's gonna buy the next
the Chinese using to buy the next watch
Chinese I know this notion that it's a
completely different race or less crazy
a different set of ideas that go through
there but I will say that I got a
thoughtful email yesterday from a friend
in Hong Kong saying you know when you
walk into a meeting in London the guy
walks into the meeting they look at your
shoes if you walk into a meeting a Hong
Kong they look at your watch and that
that's an important sort of status
symbol that does little large in that
very brand conscious place or gold Rolex
yeah just because it gives you baller
status means this could change you know
turn the dial for Apple I don't close
the deal well no not to to turn into the
dell prep load the samples an apple of
luxury brand and it might make a
difference for that particular purchaser
of the watch they don't care about the
store value I'm going rose gold Daytona
over the Iowa